so like he just said my name is Andy
Moakler I live in Chicago Illinois in
the United States and I'm a senior
front-end developer at Shopify I work on
our merchant marketing team so what that
means is I build experiences like this
one or this one which help people who
run their business on Shopify learn more
about their stores performance and build
a better business so the first one was a
dashboard we built and then this live
view we built for last Black Friday
Cyber Monday and it allows you to see
your store traffic in real time and we
built all of these products with
typescript and react today I'm going to
talk about how typescript ruined my life
but in a good way so I'll start out by
chatting about typescript in me a little
bit so my first exposure to typescript
was actually about four years ago is
that my first developer job I had no
idea what I was doing I didn't
understand any of the typescript code
and it really scared me away from it at
the time I I didn't understand what a
class was and they were using classes
everywhere and that just made no sense
so fast-forward a few more years now
weird about two years ago I'm working at
Shopify things have changed I understand
things slightly better at this point and
a co-worker of mine started doing
experiment to see if we could rewrite
our analytics stuff in react and he was
using flow for type checking and I
started to dive in and help him out a
little bit and I really liked the
experience with flow and it turned out
that we didn't use a lot of those
experiments only one of the files ended
up in production and we still use it to
this day but we kind of moved away from
flow but at the time I learned that
there was another team at Shopify that
was exploring what we wanted to do to
rewrite our text fat stack and one of
the parts of that was using typescript
and so as as a company we started
switching to typescript and since we
were writing react on the analytics team
we slowly started to move over as well
and the rest is history
and now whenever I start a project
without JavaScript I feel sort of a deep
sense of guilt or without
script a deep sense of guilt I feel like
really uncomfortable like I'm missing
out on all the great features that
typescript gives me so next let's talk
about typescript and all of you so there
are a lot of reasons to use a type
system with JavaScript and there's a lot
of reasons not to use a type system with
JavaScript and it'll be up to you to
sort of figure out if using types is a
good fit for your project and if it's a
good fit for the developers on your team
also typescript is just one example
there's a lot of type systems for
javascript these days if typescript
doesn't feel quite right you can try
something like flow or something like
reason that will give you a lot of the
same powers but won't be exactly what I
show today and also what I'm hoping to
that you all get out of this talk is
that I hope that you understand why you
should explore a type system for your
projects and why you should consider it
and play around with it and then we're
gonna do like a quick run-through of
some basic syntax so if you've never
seen typed JavaScript before you'll know
a little more about it by the end of
this and then I'm gonna show a couple
basic examples of how you can get
started with a project today and be
running typescript in your code bases
alright so I want to start with a brief
disclaimer um originally this slide said
everything I'm about to say is a lie but
that seemed a little too harsh for the
reality but I just want to remind you
that type systems and the types that you
write and the types that other people
write are all written by humans so you
still have to be defensive when you
write typed JavaScript a lot of the same
rules apply you should really think
about this exactly how you think about
your normal JavaScript but just with
some slight adjustments also another
disclaimer typescript is a bit of extra
work to get going you have to find the
types for the packages you're using
which for the most part already exists
and you have to write a couple type
annotations as you go but in my opinion
it is worth the extra work alright so
let's talk about why to use types the
first and this is the most important one
to me is that types make your code way
more self documenting so doc
imitation is really hard as a developer
you may be right you know read me with
your component or with your function or
with your library but you have to
remember to go back and update that
readme as you go and that can be hard
and maybe you instead put comments
inline in your code but again you have
to remember to update them and it's easy
for them to get out of sync it can be
pretty hard to express the concepts of
your code through those comments but
with a type system you're annotating the
actual code so you know that it's always
going to be in sync with how your code
is behaving if you say that something is
a string and you have typescript compile
it and the compiler passes well that
thing is going to be a string and when
you look through your application you
can have a reasonable amount of
certainty that whatever the type system
says that those variables or parameters
are going to be that's what they will be
second it lets the computer keep track
of context instead of you and your team
so when you start a project maybe it's
just you and you have about a thousand
lines of code and for the most part you
can remember where you've called certain
functions maybe you write a new function
and a month later you change the
parameters that it takes and you can
sort of keep track of you know I I
called it in this file and in this file
and you can go through and you can
update those things and there's some
naive tools you can use to help you out
with that you can do a global search on
your project a little less naive you can
have really good tests that try to catch
those sorts of changes but it's really
useful to have one more thing trying to
keep all of that context for you and
it's even better when it's a computer
doing that so now if you change the
signature of a function the compiler is
going to catch that across your whole
codebase anything that calls into that
function is going to have to satisfy the
compiler before it will successfully
compiled next it helps you avoid some
common pitfalls so typescript has done a
great job of building a great ecosystem
one of my favorite things is that I am
terrible at remembering the Dom API I
can't remember if query selector all
returns an array or a node list and I
never remember what you can call on a
node list I never remember what can
return undefined versus an empty array
or an empty list and typescript will
help you catch those sorts of things so
when you maybe don't anticipate that
something will be NOLA undefined
typescript will help to tell you that
and then the last two points sort of go
together so it encourages API driven
development which means that you really
focus on your API as you go in
JavaScript sometimes it's easy to just
push through an options hash and you
slowly add things to that and before you
know it without really having it well
documented somewhere you can be passing
in you know fifteen or twenty options or
something like that with typescript you
have to be explicit about what's getting
passed on that options object and so it
really helps you pay attention to your
API and pay attention to how you're
designing your code and how it's
interfacing with other parts of your
application and then finally to go along
with that there's some really amazing
development and tools typescript has an
amazing ecosystem and this is like not
the best reason to use something having
developer tools get built around every
language and every framework but
currently right now the dev tools for
typescript are really awesome all right
so I'm gonna try to cruise through the
syntax stuff pretty quickly give you a
little taste
I really recommend the typescript Docs
they're pretty easy to understand and
there's some great getting started
guides there but I wanted to give a
little taste of what it's like to see
some typescript code and to write it so
here's like the hello world of types so
you'll see that I have three simple
identifiers x' here i have city which is
a constant and then i have this type
annotation afterwards so anytime you see
a colon and then that like yellow
highlighted identifier there that's
going to be a type annotation so I'm
saying that City is a string and then I
sign it to Amsterdam and I do the same
thing for this cash prize number
variable and a loading boolean and so
now I have types in my JavaScript it's
pretty simple and so now you can see I
have this little red squiggly that's
what it looks like in vs code but
depending on the plug-in or whatever
you're using it'll look a little
different but it's telling me that I
can't call index of on a boolean on
loading so that's great but typescript
is a little smarter than that
so it can actually infer the types here
so just by assigning it to a string or a
number or
a boolean it can learn that loading is
still boolean and it still gives me that
helpful hint at the bottom and even as I
reassign the variable it'll keep track
that maybe could be a boolean or a
string or a boolean or a number but it
also kind of helps you catch those
things they're not always the best
okay array is so you can do a very
similar thing if you have a list of
strings for example like we do here I
have this foods variable and I can
assign it a list of these strings so I
push in all of these emoji strings here
and when I do this assignment it's happy
and when I call push which is an array
method its happy about it but if I try
to do anything that is a little unusual
it'll get mad at me and it'll throw me
an error so here if I try to assign it
to a list of numbers or if I try to push
in a boolean or call a method that
doesn't exist on an array it's going to
help me notice that all right functions
so this is where it gets really
interesting so far you were probably
thinking like when I declare a variable
I can just like look a couple lines
above where I am and see what it is but
with a function usually we're gonna be
writing some modules and we're gonna be
importing and exporting and ham it's a
little bit harder to remember what
exactly a function takes in and what it
gives us back so here we have this
reverse function you'll see that word is
typed as a string and then there's
another type annotation which is the
return type and then inside we just have
normal JavaScript it's able to infer
everything else so it knows the join
returns a string at the end and if I try
to reverse racecar it's happy because I
told it that it should expect a string
but if I try to reverse a boolean it's
going to be upset with me and again
typescript is a bit smarter than that so
I try to write typescript as close to
JavaScript as I possibly can and only
sort of do like the bare necessities so
that it looks pretty normal still and
here we can omit that return type
because the compiler is able to infer it
can look at it and say join it's gonna
give me back a string and I know that
that's what it's going to return all
right interfaces so an interface is sort
of like a typed object so this looks
similar to like plain JavaScript object
syntax at this point it's probably
feeling like a bit of like a fire hose
of information don't worry we're almost
to the end of the syntax part
but uh here we declare an interface I'm
calling it person and then I have the
properties and their types inside of
that interface
so I've name which is a string naive age
which is a number and then when I create
an object that I want to be of this
person interface I need to make sure to
supply it with a name which is a string
and an age which is a number that's also
really helpful for functions because now
we can pass these objects around and I
can name the types and I can name the
interfaces and typescript is able to
infer things from it so here it's going
to expect a person object when I
calculate their birth year I guess this
would be yeah their birth year and you
can also infer that this is going to
return a number so 20 18 minus another
number is going to give me back a number
all right and then finally type aliases
so this is sort of like the most
powerful tool in typescript it sort of
rolls everything else up into one you
have this type keyword and then you can
name your type and then you have a lot
of tools that you can use so here I'm
just showing you guys the Union so the
pipe operator you can just think about
that as an or a union so vegetable can
be broccoli or carrot fruit can be
orange or Kiwi or watermelon you can
chain these together so an ingredient
could be a vegetable or a fruit if I
have like a juice stand for example and
then in my code if I say that juice has
to be an ingredient array and I give it
broccoli and watermelon the compiler is
happy but if I give it bread which is
not a fruit or a vegetable it's not one
of my ingredients then it's going to
flag it and ask me to fix it
all right so I have a couple of demos to
show you how you can get started with
typescript so we're gonna start out with
just basic compilation and I have this
project hopefully it's big enough and to
avoid problems with the Wi-Fi I've just
done one step ahead of time would just
start a project and then add typescript
as a dev dependency okay so you can just
do yarn add dev or NPM save dev
typescript and I'll create a new file
called index TS and I'll write a
function so let's do a greeting function
and we'll take a name which is a string
and then we're just gonna console.log it
so hello name okay and then if I try to
call that here if I pass in something
that's not a string it might be a little
hard to see but I get this error and
it'll give me an error message that says
argument of type true is not assignable
to parameter of type string so it's
telling me true is not a string I need
to try to give it a string and so if I
pass through something like Amsterdam je
s then it's going to be happy and you'll
see all kinds of awesome tooling here so
if I just hover over greet it will give
me the function signature it also tells
me that it returns void right now
because I don't have a return statement
anywhere in there and to compile this I
run TSC which is the typescript compiler
that's included when you install
typescript and then I pass it the
filename and that finishes and we can
see the compiled output here so for this
it obviously isn't super exciting it was
a pretty simple function that we wrote
but it does compile it down it I think
that this by default is doing es 5 maybe
es 3 I can't remember and it's all happy
if I come back in here and give it
something that it's not happy about so
this is kind of to show what it would be
like if you don't use these specific dev
tools I can run yarn TSC again and it'll
give me an error message it's a little
hard to see in there because there's
some other output from yarn but it says
argument of type true is not assignable
to parameter of type string like we saw
before so without any of these dev tools
you can get started with typescript and
you can start compiling sort of simple
scripts like this now most of us are
probably writing applications that are
slightly more complex than this four
line program that I wrote just now
and I want to give you a little taste of
what it might be like to get started
with that
typescript works with pretty much any
tools you're using so if you're using
webpack and you have a more complex app
typescript works great with that but I'm
gonna show a demo right now with parcel
which for me if you're just trying to do
something pretty
symbol with typescript is the best way
to go because it supports it so I'll
open this project up and in this one
I've done a few more things ahead of
time I've installed three dependencies
react and react DOM and then Shopify
Polaris which that's our design system
and we have a set of react components
we're gonna use those to see what it
looks like to consume a library that is
also typed with typescript and then in
our dev dependencies
I have typescript like before I have
Parcel bundler which is gonna bundle our
code for us and then I have two types
packages here so these come from a
repository called definitely typed I
think last year is like the most
contributed to repository on github most
packages that you use probably already
have type definitions in there it's
really easy to go out and get them so I
just installed these two and now I have
the types for react and react Dom and
they're very well maintained and we're
pretty much ready to go so I won't go
into the nuts and bolts of parcel it's
like a whole other talk a whole other
issue it's pretty easy to get started
with but here I have a react app and
this boilerplate should look pretty
familiar I import some CSS I import
react and react Dom a provider is
required by Polaris you don't need to
worry about that too much
and then I render this into the Dom
alright so let's start writing some
typescript with react so you'll see that
I have this app class and extends react
component if I ask Visual Studio code
what I can use in here you'll see that
from the types I have a lot of help it
tells me which mess methods have become
unsafe recently but I just want to do
render and I'm gonna return pretty
simple little app here that won't work
okay
and we'll wait for this to build it
might take a second alright so you can
see really tiny up in the corner we have
hello world so so far again this looks
exactly this doesn't look like
typescript at all this is just normal
you know react Jase likes kind of code
that we always write and you'll find
that that happens a lot with typescript
that you're you know writing away and
your typescript files but really you're
just writing normal JavaScript and every
once in a while you have a small change
that helps the compiler know a little
bit more about your code so let's import
from the Polaris package to see how that
works so I'm gonna bring in Shopify
Polaris and here this is able to list
everything that's available to me so
there's all these functions and
components I'm gonna pick this page
component alright alright so it might be
a little bit tough to see but here we
have a red underline underneath the page
component if I scroll to the bottom of
this error message it says property
title is missing in type and then it
gives me the type that I've passed to
that react element so what this is
telling me is that a developer who wrote
this page component marked the title
prop as required and this is awesome so
now without having to go into the
documentation or maybe I've forgotten
this it's been a while since I've used
this page component the compiler can
tell me ahead of time that I'm missing
something that's required for this to
work and so I'll add a title and now you
can see hopefully that there's no more
red underlined so it's happy with
everything I've done if I come back here
we have this page component it's past
the title through and we have hello
world and there's a bunch of optional
properties that we can also use so all
of them are listed down here so for
example if I want full width which is
optional I can click on that and type
script will help me know right now it's
true if I try to pass something invalid
it'll flag it for me and without having
to you know save or run or
anything to this code it's able to tell
me whether it's valid or not so take
that away all right so that was a pretty
pretty quick overview but hopefully it
makes sense a little bit how easy it is
to get started with typescript all right
so I'm gonna leave with a couple of
thoughts about writing effective
typescript so what should you do to
avoid sort of letting typescript ruin
your life in a bad way instead of a good
way so the first one is treat your types
like normal JavaScript that goes for all
typescript code only write what you need
to write it so that the compiler can
understand it and don't try to treat it
like something separate this goes for
code organization as well whatever
standards and best practices you've
discovered on your team for organizing
your modules or your components or
whatever it may be
organize your types in a similar way
make them easy to discover make them
easy to use in the same way that
everything else in your app is don't
suddenly think that you're writing
something totally new the next one is to
put some effort into your types and
avoid any wherever possible in fact
there is a flag you can tell the
compiler that will be a little more
aggressive about rejecting when you use
any occasionally you can be tempting
you're maybe in a hurry and you just
sort of want to like skip over the type
checking part but the most frustrating
thing to me is when I know I've been in
a hurry in the past and I go to use some
code that I wrote before and suddenly I
don't have all of that help that I'm so
used to a typescript like it's sort of
ruins the whole experience so put effort
into your types sometimes things can be
a little difficult to express but it's
always worthwhile and you can express
pretty much anything I mean if you
really if you're a fan of duck typing
you can you know make duck typing work
with typescript you can make pretty much
anything you can write functions that
generate types all those sorts of things
all right and then this is my personal
opinion but I think that steering clear
of type inheritance is a good idea so
try to keep your types really simple
never have like long inheritance chains
four types and then also avoid clever
types so like I said before you can
express pretty much anything with the
type system but sometimes those types
can be a little too clever and it makes
them a little bit hard to use
all right thank you so much you can find
me here that's my handle pretty much
everywhere and yeah thank you give it up
for Andy
[Applause]